speculative realism it's an adjective
plus a noun and as such it's one among
many options i've listed here just some
of the different kinds of realism that
are out there today the agential realism
of karen brad
critical realism very well known in the
uk of roy baskar
the internal realism of analytic
philosopher hillary putnam
new realism in italy and germany
maurizio ferraris and marcus gabriel
the quasi-realism of simon blackburn who
i believe is speaking at this festival
and finally naive realism a kind of
insult that anti-realists throw at
realists as if all forms of naive
as though all forms of realism were
naive and should be shunned for that
very reason
speculative realism is also a phrase of
this sort
one of the reasons this happens that you
get lots of descriptive phrases with
realism in them is that realism can mean
so many different kinds of things
and so we have to specify exactly what
speculative realism meant
now i've put here a slide of edmond
husserl and martin heidegger his
renegade students this is presumably
from sometime in the early 1920s
it's the best photo of the two together
i could find you can't see lucille's
face
you can think of hustle and heidegger uh
as the two founding figures of what we
call continental philosophy today
you could put it back further and
include hegel if you want but in terms
of contemporary continental philosophy
whistle and heidegger are two of the
major canonical figures one thing they
both have in common
is that they both didn't think very
highly of the question of the external
world does the external world exist
outside the mind
both of them tended to dismiss it as
what they call a pseudo problem
for whosoever conscious life always
amounts to what he calls intending
some object uh if i wish i wish for
something if i judge i'm judging
something
if i uh speak i'm speaking about
something some object even if it's
non-existent
i can hallucinate a centaur but there's
still a centaur there as the object
of my hallucination so uh
as far as who's concerned consciousness
is pointed at objects whether we like it
or not
and so there's no point in wondering how
we leap from outside of our mind into a
world with objects
heidegger's criticism of the realist
question is similar
heidegger thinks that humans are always
already thrown into the world
and we are counting on and relying on
practical devices
we are we are not primarily looking at
the world i'm primarily right now using
the chair
using the atmospheric oxygen in the room
to stay alive by breathing using the
smooth function of my bodily organs to
stay alive
and so forth so for both of them we're
always
already involved with things with the
world and therefore there's no
point in coming up with complex
epistemological maneuvers to try to
prove that we can get out of the mind
into another world
and so for this reason realism was never
taken
all that seriously in the continental
tradition with the exception of nikolai
hartmann the german philosopher whose
the rough contemporary of heidegger is
experiencing a revival
these days but he was so marginalized
compared to russo and heidegger who
really set the tone
and so if you had written a dissertation
in the continental philosophy department
25 years ago or 20 years ago when i was
doing it
uh on the existence of the external
worlds people would be smirking and
chuckling behind your back because it
wasn't considered a serious problem
this is the four of us at 2007 in
goldsmiths
so within this context uh speculative
realism
uh tried to argue for realism within a
continental
context would have been not news at all
in the analytic philosophy context where
realism
has always been a very robust presence
but in the continental uh tradition this
was
uh fairly controversial and i think it's
had an effect you
you hear more people now offering
realist interpretations of philosophers
such as varied on
and heidegger who wouldn't have been
associated with the world
word realism at all and i think a lot of
that is people responding to what the
speculative realist did
i want to say a couple of other things
about this slide before we get going
uh the first is that you see four white
guys here
and this is an era when in philosophy in
particular we're especially concerned
with diversity and
inclusion so i sometimes have asked why
was it for white guys
well the simplest answer to that is that
it was four people who knew
loosely knew each other brassiere knew
on the right new ian hamilton grant on
the left
and there there are my second from the
left i knew contact
somewhat from having met him in paris
and so ray brasia and i simply brought
together
each of us brought together one
acquaintance we knew with similar
philosophical interests
and we combined for this event the other
thing is you have to remember this was
not a very prestigious group at the time
all four of us were quite marginalized
in our profession 13 years ago
not very visible we were starting to
publish
uh but did not have especially
prestigious
academic positions or or acclaim at that
time and so it was a
meeting of the marginalized and so if
anyone else had wanted to join us at the
time
of any background we would have been
more than delighted so that's that's my
answer to that question
now there's another question which has
to do with um
the basis of this philosophical movement
usually when you see
a group of philosophers come together
there's some shared tradition or some
shared inspiring figure who they're all
working out of so you see heideggerians
inspired by heidegger delusions inspired
by zulus
and so forth what was interesting about
this group
is that we don't really have any shared
philosophical heroes there's no
philosopher that all four of us were
passionate about
in fact in many cases the other members
disliked strongly dislike
the favorite philosopher of each of the
four of us the only shared influence
among the four of us was the horror
writer h.p lovecraft
and we all had our own interpretations
of lovecraft i've written a book about
lovecraft
called weird realism and now lovecraft
has
experienced a pop culture resurgence
there's a popular television series
um there's a board a role-playing game
uh people are reading lovecraft in
greater numbers than before
usually this happens to people in their
teenage years in my case
uh i didn't read lovecraft in my late
30s so i was a very late comer to the
party if you like reading lord of the
rings for the first time in your late
30s it's usually
something that teenagers get excited
about first
so let me go now briefly through each of
these members
and summarize what each of the spans of
speculative realism
uh work on because each of the four
philosophies are very different
even though we were all lovecraft fans
and we were all continental philosophers
working in a
largely anti-realist tradition trying to
make a vigorous case
for realist philosophy ian hamilton
grant looking good there in
bristol at the university of west of
england one of the nicest people i know
ian is inspired largely by the
philosophies of duluz
and fwj shelling from the german
idealist times
and you could safely say that ian is
focused on nature as a process
nature is a continuous process of
becoming
that uh generates individual objects
only through what he calls retardations
there's this primal continuous force
that for some reason gets obstructed
here and there and gives rise to cats
and bicycles and
buildings and trees and what we normally
think of is
the major autonomous entities that
populate our world
ray barassier who has now in the
american university of beirut
he was at the time at middlesex
university in london before they closed
their philosophy program
in 2010 i believe it was uh rape racier
is
probably arguably the most pessimistic
philosopher in the western tradition
since schopenhauer and edward van harman
uh rossier thinks he stresses not only
that the universe will become extinct
someday
he says that since the universe will
become extinct someday you're already
dead
you may think you're alive but you're
already dead
um nihilism needle unbound is the title
of his
his book and uh he thinks that
science and science-based philosophy are
speculative tools
that enhance our incentives to be
nihilists
that there is a gap between any
scientific theory and reality and
irremedial
irremediable gap and therefore what
science is really doing is it's not
trying to teach us positive truths about
the worlds because though
each of those scientific theories lasts
only for a little while before it's
shown to be inadequate
that scientific theories are there to
show us the
ultimate nullity of each of our theories
about the cosmos and it's a progressive
process we're becoming less and less
attached to this world
as we uh become acquainted with the
nothingness of it
who was then a tutor at the economy
superior since then has been called
to a professorship at the sorbonne
executive realism made him a lot more
visible
i've written an entire book on maya sue
whose philosophy fascinates me
maesu is a realist in the sense that he
he starts with a conflict of what he
calls an apparea between
two different truths on the one hand
he says that it's true that
anything we say about the world is
simply us saying it
anything we say about the world is
correlated with us he calls this
correlationism
there's this idea that if i say
something about the world it's my saying
the thing about the world it's not
uh me standing in a vacuum initially
stating true propositions about the
world i'm trapped in a correlate
between myself and the world and so
statement about the world
is a statement about the world as given
to me
i mention this because sometimes people
view massive straightforwardly as a
critic of correlations
he actually is quite an admirer of
correlationism he thinks correlation the
correlationists have a good argument
if i try to speak about something on the
outside of the mind i'm speaking about
it so therefore it's also inside the
mind i can't really escape that circle
initially
now however to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas